RJ Barrett dances inside and scores all
the piastic person about the game of
basketball and you know he's been very
helpful to the NBA the WNBA's Jarrod
knocks down RJ's dad was Rowan's played
at st. John's and played overseas more
points than any other player in Lipscomb
history Barrett to the rim lays it up
and lays it in Virginia Barrett aim the
better you're going to get you are not a
finished product he was really good he
was a great 1717 and in Robinson the
people that come in the building is
really what makes that build insane and
makes it hum Oxford
farik against Jones takes him inside and
scores
okay it's true that they put on the
internet but what is true is I had hopes
not hop so I know what block Cavanaugh
put the jump up the set of my RJ berry
my Wooten who has been a pogo stick
leaper here Barrett's off the high glass
must-see TV Memphis Tigers NOx rises
Barrett for three RJ Barrett great way
to end it for him come to get a win and
then have a good game cap it off for
three well there's one assist